et voilà c'était les 150 des citoyens
s'engagent après la convention aux
citoyenne pour le climat un formidable
documentaire réalisé par vous Baptiste
Roger luchères bonjour merci de
participer à Z la Zone d'Éducation
documentaire alors vous n'êtes pas venu
seul il y a Frédéric Joly à côté de vous
bonjour vous êtes l'un des membres
fondateurs de la fresque pour le climat
alors c'est une association qui utilise
un outil la fresque pour parler des
enjeux climatiques alerter les gens
autour de autour de cette thématique
vous nous donnerez évidemment de plus en
plus détails sur son fonctionnement et
sur cette association tout au long de
l'émission une émission préparer
façonner sculptée par vous les élèves
bonjour
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir travaillé
sur ce film alors vous l'avez regardé
décortiquer vous je sais je sais que
vous avez plein de questions à poser à
nos invités parce que vous les avez
préparé mais juste avant juste avant de
leur poser toutes ces questions
j'aimerais d'abord faut connaître votre
sentiment sur ce documentaire comment
vous l'avez trouvé Nathan on t'écoute
c'est un documentaire touchant et qui
nous touche chacun d'entre nous et qui
nous a qui nous interpelle en quoi ça
t'interpellé toi
sur le climat qui fait les c'était
urgent et qui fallait prendre soin de la
planète dès maintenant j'ai vu d'autres
mains se lever oui dis-moi moi je
trouvais très bien et aussi fait
réfléchir Marie c'était simple à
comprendre et
je trouvais que ça passait vite c'était
intéressant ok d'autres oui dis-moi moi
je l'ai trouvé plutôt intéressant et il
n'était pas ennuyeux quand je vous dis
climat
quel est le premier mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit allez tiens
me crise crise d'autres mots
urgence
c'est à vous maintenant de poser des
questions à nos invités et on va
commencer par être au matin tu avais une
question
s'adresse à vous mais ce rouge lors du
visionnage de votre documentaire une
chose marque l'esprit les scènes ils
sont diverses variées avec des plans en
extérieur les scènes pascals et 150 ou
dans leur quotidien ou encore des scènes
d'archives des plans d'archivesment je
me demande donc comment avez-vous réussi
à trouver
une balance un équilibre dans
l'alternance de vos plans qui a permis
ce résultat final
l'idée c'est qu'en fait tu racontes
quelque chose donc les personnes moi je
raconte quelque chose à travers le film
et puis chacun des personnes qui sont
dans le film aussi racontent leur
expérience leur conviction et donc le
film il se construit ce monte avec ce
matériau principal qui ce qu'on appelle
les sonores en général c'est quand les
gens prennent la parole les expriment
quelque chose et ensuite les sonores tu
fais en sorte qu'ils essaient de se
répondre les uns les autres et que de
construire un discours ou quelque ou en
tout cas une réflexion et après tu as un
centre de plans qui servent à donner en
fait de l'ampleur donner de la comment
dirais un décor à ce que les gens disent
est-ce que les gens ont vécu moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de montrer à quel
point une expérience comme cette
convention citoyenne peut changer
n'importe quel citoyen citoyennes
françaises d'avoir quelque chose qui
soit un peu un panel de 250 et d'avoir
retrouvé la diversité qui avait dans ce
panel de Français et française et
ensuite après on a décidé de choisir 5 6
citoyens et citoyens en particulier et
ce en particulier ceux qui avaient
vraiment des idées de changer quelque
chose à leur vie ou de s'engager d'une
manière considérée conséquente et
importante après la Convention on dirait
que l'expérience de la convention de la
convention les a tellement changé qu'ils
ont eu envie de faire plus en tant que
citoyen
pour alerter sur climat il faut que la
France
change sur les questions qui m'a ils ont
marqué ces personnages
qui m'a marqué c'est la fille de 17 ans
puisque je trouve que ça nous donne une
bonne idée de ce qu'est la jeunesse
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que les
gens pensent de la jeunesse aujourd'hui
et ça nous fait aussi nous rendre compte
qu'on peut faire également on peut faire
la même chose et vous Frédéric vous
l'avez vu évidemment ce documentaire
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
j'ai beaucoup aimé le documentaire
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que c'est un documentaire qui donne un
visage sur cette histoire des visages
et le fait de voir des personnes
marquées par la vie parler de cette
expérience
exprimer des émotions dans lesquelles on
sentait la force de conviction de la
fierté je trouvais ça un réjouissant et
quand comme moi et plein d'autres on
essaye de lever des masses populaires
sur ces sujets moi ça m'a ça m'a donné à
chair de poule et le deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est que il était assez
court
45 minutes et il mettait le doigt sur
moi ce qui m'a paru le plus important
mais ça avec cette convention c'est je
prends 150 personnes tirées au sort on
prend le temps de les former ils
arrivent à un niveau de conviction et de
modification de motivation qui est bien
plus important que des militants ou bien
évidemment le monde politique et donc là
le message était
très bien passé et vous les élèves quand
vous avez fini de regarder le doc est-ce
que vous êtes dit j'aurais bien aimé
être tirer au sort
proposition qui ont été prises j'aurais
sûrement été déçu oui Enzo
[Musique]
ça apporte une expérience dans le milieu
de l'oral tout simplement et puis
j'aurais bien aimé apporter ma trace
dans tout ce qui est
politique
au sort parce que je trouve que dans
l'enseignement scolaire la question du
climat n'est pas assez elle est pas
assez posée et on a un enseignement mais
il est très faible et on a souvent que
connaissance des conséquences et non pas
des causes et du coup on peut pas trop
pour faire quelque chose vous êtes
d'accord avec Kahina Nathan oui parce
que on va encore des personnes qui
jettent leurs déchets par terre dans
certains pays on envoie nos déchets dans
des pays pauvres pour des décharges
publics et c'est horrible de faire ça et
il faudrait changer le monde changer les
politiques et changer notre mode de vie
Fatoumata je pense que dans un premier
temps je me serais dit c'est une
pression assez forte et ce que je serais
capable moi de me dire je représente
d'autres citoyens et ce que je vais pas
mettre mes envies à moi d'abord par
rapport aux envies de tout le monde
c'est une question assez compliqué je
trouve mais je l'aurais fait oui pour
l'expérience et surtout pour me dire
j'ai participé à ça et au moins j'aurais
tenté de faire quelque chose le
troisième c'est trop tard on peut plus
rien faire pour le climat
et on va poursuivre avec toi Angeline
j'ai pu constater en tant que Lycène que
les documentaires n'étaient pas très
populaires chez les jeunes elle vous
donc penser à un autre format pour
informer toucher les plus jeunes avant
qu'ils comprennent les enjeux
climatiques et démocratiques alors je me
permets de compléter c'était peut-être
pas le but de votre documentaire
je l'ai pas pensé pour les jeunes en
particulier après évidemment je pense
que c'est important de relier ces sujets
là auprès des jeunes et c'est un reste
un vrai défi de savoir comment les
atteindre et comment quels sont les bons
biais les bons médias les bons formats
a trouvé le film clair pas trop ennuyant
pas trop compliqué donc déjà ça se
trouve que c'est déjà pas mal
bien sûr bien sûr du coup je me tourne
vers vous Frédéric alors déjà ce format
là du documentaire vous c'est pas
quelque chose que vous utilisez avec la
fresque du climat mais vous en pensez
quoi comment vous intégrez le l'image et
ce type de format dans votre réflexion
je pense que tous les formats sont
nécessaires on a besoin de tous les
formats pour toucher la plus grande
partie de la population et c'est la
diversité des formats qui va nous donner
plus de chances de faire passer les
messages il y a eu des documentaires
avant chacun a apporté sa pierre à
l'édifice avec la fresque on adresse
quelque chose d'autre la fraise c'est
quoi c'est un atelier qui est ludique et
collaboratif on se met dans une salle
tous ensemble on va passer un moment
d'échange significatif c'est dure trois
heures mais le côté interactif le rang
peut-être plus accessible à toutes les
parties de la population donc c'est
juste un autre format qui a été créé par
l'auteur du jeu qui s'appelle Cédric
Ringenbach et ben voilà qui permet de
progresser d'une nouvelle manière dans
les sphères de la société
Alicia tu as une question à ce sujet
donc la fresque elle a été repris dans
plus de 50 pays je crois école collège
lycée quand vous avez créé cette fresque
en 2018 est-ce que quel a été votre
objectif premier et est-ce que vous
attendiez un tel impact un tel
engouement autour de justement ce projet
la presque a été créée par un auteur que
donc Cédric qui a créé ça autour de 2015
effectivement avec quelques copains on
s'est réuni au mois de décembre 2018 en
se disant bah voilà on va en faire un
projet d'ampleur et tout de suite on a
voulu se mettre en objectif ambitieux on
avait dit un million un million de
personnes qui sont qui vont passer par
cet atelier parce que on pense on
pensait que il y avait un déficit de
connaissance des sujets climatiques dans
toutes les sphères de la société donc
pas que dans les collèges les lycées les
écoles mais les entreprises le montent
associatif le monde politique
à tous les âges dans tous les pays donc
c'est on l'a on l'a on l'a conçu comme
un projet qui devait fédérateur ça va
bientôt faire quatre ans on a 500 000 on
vient de fêter nos premiers 500 000 on
devrait atteindre le million si tout va
bien courant 2023
donc voilà pari tenue jusqu'à présent
comment comment ça se passe au niveau
justement de l'éducation nationale
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez des
partenariats est-ce que peut vous
essayer de pousser justement vers ça
est-ce qu'on vous entend est-ce qu'on
vous écoute
l'atelier il est très apprécié dans le
monde éducatif on avait commencé plutôt
par l'éducation supérieure et maintenant
effectivement on intervient beaucoup
dans les collèges et dans les lycées
avec un programme
qui permet de faire ça donc on appelle
ça la rentrée climat parce qu'au début
on faisait ça au moment de la rentrée
mais on n'a pas un partenariat en tant
que tel avec l'Éducation nationale mais
moi ce qui m'intéresse le plus c'est des
élèves comme vous qui se disent ah bah
moi j'ai appris la fresque et je vais le
faire des enseignants qui se disent bon
j'ai peut-être pas toute la matière mais
je vais prendre la fraise je vais me
former ça dure trois heures pour se
former et je vais le donner et je vais
faire ça et même si je sais pas tout et
ben ça va permettre de faire le moment
d'échanges et c'est ça la fresque on n'a
pas besoin d'être un expert du climat
pour faire une phrase du climat
tu peux nous parler de ton expérience
c'était il y a combien de temps c'était
il y a un an c'était au début de ma
seconde c'était dans le cadre d'une
formation qu'on avait reçu aux écoles
délégués parce qu'on estimait que pour
bien agir faut d'abord être avoir de la
prévention et c'est vraiment un travail
que qu'on a tous reçu avec bienveillance
parce que c'est toujours important de
savoir
pourquoi pourquoi on se bat et pourquoi
on fait tout ça et on en ressort quand
même changé parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'en fait on a quand même un impact sur
ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui et que si
on a un impact c'est peut-être à nous de
changer aussi les choses et c'est
vraiment un beau message qu'on a eu à
travers cette fraise je suis ravi
d'entendre ça et c'est quelque chose
qu'on aimerait populariser dans les
lycées un peu partout en France et à
l'étranger on va poursuivre avec Gatien
moi je voulais savoir depuis combien de
temps vous aviez le projet de la fresque
pour le climat et qu'elle a été le
déclic de passer du secteur privé au
secteur associatif
très bonne question aussi moi je veux
bien très loin souvent dans mes
conférences je dis que je suis pas du
tout un écolo je panais là dedans il y a
pas si longtemps j'avais une activité
très prenante je passais mon temps dans
les avions et j'ai tout arrêté il y a
environ 50
j'ai eu plusieurs moments un moment où
je me souviens j'ai vu une carte une
carte qui présentait une image du monde
à plus 4 degrés en 2080 et où j'ai vu
l'ensemble des zones qui étaient
incompatibles avec la vie humaine dans
le monde j'ai vu ça je me suis pas
possible donc là j'ai besoin de creuser
j'ai regardé j'ai lu des trucs j'ai vu
des conférences et puis autour de 2016
qu'on a première fille est née j'ai pris
une décision consciente de dire allez
j'y vais je vais me lancer j'y connais
rien mais je vais essayer de faire
quelque chose et ce que j'ai fait c'est
que j'ai essayé de rencontrer le plus
grand nombre de gens possible et c'est
comme ça que j'ai rencontré Cédric le
créateur du jeu et c'est comme ça que
l'aventure est partie Guillaume tu avais
une question pour Bapt iste
vous montrer une élue de la CCC Héloïse
qui avait que des bénévoles éteignent
des éclairages publicitaires quel regard
portez-vous sur sur ce type d'action
j'ai montré cette séquence que c'était
la manière pour Héloïse de s'engager je
pense qu'il y a plein de formes
d'engagement possible et je me suis pas
je mets pas de de comment dirais-je
d'échelle ou de notes à ces engagements
là chacun les siens et chacun fait avec
ses convictions ses moyens son temps
j'ai pas de jugement par rapport à ça
c'est une séquence qui est venue
d'Éloïse ce que on discutant avec elle
on lui demandait mais quelle action tu
as sur le terrain et donc voilà j'ai
suivi Éloïse qui est un soir décidé
d'éteindre toutes les toutes les
enseignes qui ne servent à rien qui sont
un tout petit
[Musique]
comment vous regardez vous ce type
d'action là c'est tout à fait
complémentaire on est dans de l'action
c'est bien sympathique on est d'accord
d'éteindre un éclairage public la nuit
donc personne n'a besoin dans un moment
où on a besoin de sobriété donc ce sont
des actions qui sont non violentes qui
sont sympathiques et qui poussent à
l'engagement donc évidemment que ça
rentre dans un ensemble de quelque chose
qu'on va appeler la cause donc on essaye
d'interpeller Héloïse elle interpelle à
cette manière et bravo Héloïse et bravo
à tous ses camarades
avec votre équipe sur l'île de la
Réunion on peut donc se demander le coût
financier et environnemental d'un tel
projet elle est pas mal cette question
elle est bien
en fait j'ai pas été à la Réunion j'ai
pas pris j'ai pas été tourné La Réunion
pour c'est la question environnementale
pour pas prendre l'avion donc j'ai
trouvé une équipe si j'étais sur place
donc c'est un Réunionnais qui est allé
filmer c'était séquence
jade comme nous le savons la pollution
est due aux hommes et en majeure partie
aux entreprises telles que totale et du
coup on voulait savoir si vous
intervenez dans ces grandes entreprises
et selon vous comment les rendre acteurs
du changement climatique alors très
bonne question et merci donc oui on
intervient et oui on est contacté on est
très sollicité par les grandes
entreprises
donc nous on est très contents parce que
ça permet de faire passer les messages
et on n'est pas naïf non plus
c'est à dire que quand on fait des
fraises en dans une entreprise on ne
gêne personne on est encore dans un
exercice pédagogique donc on soit bien
d'accord quand on fait des fraises dans
l'entreprise on va arriver avec une idée
de transformationnelle qui est comment
je vais inciter les acteurs de
l'entreprise et les décideurs en
particulier à prendre ce sujet au
sérieux et à changer et à changer quoi
en particulier ce qu'on appelle les
modèles d'affaires c'est-à-dire à chaque
fois que je fais un euro dans une
entreprise quand je gagne un euro quel
est le coût environnemental de 7 euros
et comment je réduis drastiquement ce
coût environnemental c'est ça le sujet
est-ce que pour autant vous avez
l'impression
qu'on vous utilise
oui c'est tout à fait l'impression qu'on
utilise et c'est le jeu nous on a besoin
de pénétrer le monde des décideurs
politiques et économiques donc on prend
les codes de l'entreprise j'ai travaillé
17 ans entreprises je les connais
maintenant une fois qu'on est là la
question c'est est-ce qu'on a la parole
libre ou pas et c'est là que le jeu
devient intéressant c'est est-ce qu'on
est capable de poser des choses et de
mettre dans la tête des gens qui vont
participer à ces fresques quelque chose
qui est de l'ordre de l'humain qui de se
dire bon sang mais c'est vrai que moi
j'aimerais bien faire quelque chose
là-dessus et je vous assure parmi des
personnalités très importantes dans des
fresques on a vu des moments d'émotion
très fort et des gens réagir avec une
authenticité qui m'a moins m'a
décontenancé
il est déjà arrivé qu'on vous dise moi
stop ça suffit là non alors
pas vous sortez
mais presque
vous allez pas nous dire qui anecdote
mais effectivement pour une fresque dans
un
comité de direction d'un grand groupe
j'ai eu un coup de téléphone la veille
on me dit attention Frédéric on tape
s'abonner la planche avec des gens
avaient éduqué notamment la personne qui
était à la tête du groupe pour que ça ne
se passe pas correctement donc la
personne en début d'atelier arrive et me
dit c'est vous l'animateur alors vous
avez une mission aujourd'hui c'est de ne
pas nous déprimer
donc ce qu'elle me disait c'est moi je
ne veux surtout pas voir la réalité en
face essayez pas de me la faire regarder
pas trop tard moi j'étais là donc j'ai
fait ce que je savais faire le mieux et
je l'ai fait mais alors avec une force
déchaînée par rapport à d'habitude
on vous a pas demandé de sortir à la fin
quoi mais je suis pas revenu
ok ok moi le message est passé enfin en
tout cas on l'espère Maeva ma question
elle s'adresse à vous Baptiste que j'ai
lu cher est-ce que votre tournage vous
a-t-il fait changer votre vision sur le
changement climatique si oui comment
voyez-vous les choses maintenant
climatique ce que j'étais suffisamment
informé avant le fofing
non ce que ça est-ce que ça a changé
c'est
c'est en fait c'est assez intéressant
c'est un peu la contradiction que
soulève le film c'est à dire qu'à la
fois je trouve que c'est on le film
montre vraiment et l'expérience que les
citoyens historienne qui ont participé à
la Convention
voilà dans le film c'est que c'est les
informer et qu'on donne les moyens aussi
d'agir mais en fait tu deviens militant
tu deviens un acteur du changement
on n'a jamais vu un exercice citoyen
déclenché une telle production
législative et réglementaire et ça a
permis qu'on ait une loi climat qui est
largement insuffisante mais qui malgré
tout est meilleur que si on n'avait rien
donc ça c'est quand même une victoire
que les citoyens de la Convention et que
le mouvement climat qui a participé à
faire émerger cet exercice doit pouvoir
s'attribuer
si je devais retenir une chose c'est
que quand les gens se parlent ils
trouvent des solutions
que c'est possible en fait
quotidienne quelles sont les actions que
vous mettez en place pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique il faut
qu'on soit lignée c'est-à-dire que quand
on parle climat on peut pas faire ça
dans un côté et avoir un mode de vie qui
répond pas aux normes de la sobriété de
l'autre donc premier sujet c'est arrêter
l'avion j'ai appris à utiliser le train
ça veut dire j'ai reconsidéré le voyage
ça paraît insurmontable mais c'est juste
un autre concept du voyage c'est à dire
que le temps va prendre une autre
considération j'ai considérablement
réduit ma consommation de viande j'ai
vendu ma voiture j'ai une petite voiture
électrique et les élèves vous faites
quoi dans votre vie quotidienne pour
essayer d'améliorer un petit peu les
choses Fatoumata
mais il y a quand même des bus qui
permet de venir au lycée mais je vais
quand même plutôt marcher c'est un
moment que je peux prendre pour me
calmer pour réfléchir avant de venir au
lycée juste bah admirer un peu le
paysage autour de moi et je mange moins
de viande ah oui ok
et vous autour de vous Enzo
on applique le tri pour éviter de
d'augmenter les coûts de
recyclage tout simplement et surtout on
limite tout ce qui est chauffage d'une
pour le point de vue économique aussi
écologique tout simplement moi c'est
pareil c'est de faire des petites
actions au quotidien comme par exemple
j'arrive enfin j'étais proche souvent
les ordinateurs enfin tout ce qui est
chargé j'ai pris l'habitude de faire ça
pareil la télé quand elle est allumée je
l'éteins la consommation d'eau aussi
c'est de faire attention et après bah
pareil j'ai dit aussi ma consommation de
viande avec mes parents et voilà des
petites choses comme ça au quotidien
quand je peux aller à pied quelque part
et je m'y rend comme ça à pied et voilà
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose de
bien à faire la bonne nouvelle c'est que
on a tout un monde à reconstruire on a
des valeurs à reconstruire et les
échelles sociales vont être bouleversées
là-dessus c'est une vraie chance c'est
une vraie opportunité donc le plus tôt
vous commencez le mieux alors évidemment
c'est dérisoire par rapport à l'action
politique l'action économique qui est
nécessaire mais moi je crois que c'est
que un mouvement populaire qui fera
qu'on transformera l'énorme sociale les
normes politiques et les normes quand
vous changez l'habitude de consommation
quand vous mangez moins de viande vous
achetez moins des choses qui viennent de
la terre et ben ça ne répercussion sur
tout un tissu économique derrière de
l'usine qui fabrique ou le paysan qui
élève l'éleveur tout ça ça fait ça
provoque des changements donc en fait
vos actions ont un impact qui est
important et vos actions est une classe
mais multiplié par un licencié une
nation une ville ça a encore plus impact
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
ici dans le lycée tout le monde pense
comme vous
dans Alicia il y en a encore pas mal qui
pour eux c'est pas un sujet très
important après je pense qu'on est quand
même plus averti on a quand même fait
beaucoup plus de choses que les
générations d'avant mais je pense qu'il
y a encore du travail à faire notamment
auprès de la prévention parce que du
coup l'avenir c'est un peu nous c'est un
peu les jeunes et aussi pour avoir un
meilleur futur ça passe par la
prévention des jeunes Marie je te voyais
réagir
j'ai l'impression que
par exemple je vois encore plein de gens
qui dansaient leurs déchets par terre
etc et j'ai l'impression que d'un côté
c'est il se rendent pas compte mais
aussi j'ai l'impression en fait ils sont
comme c'est pas eux qui vont ramasser
derrière bah ils sont en mode je vais
jeter tous les cas ce sera ramassé par
quelqu'un d'autre alors que je suis sûr
que chez eux bah jamais il jetterait un
papier à parterre sinon leurs parents
ils diraient mais n'est pas est-ce que
vous vous sentez angoissé par la suite
oui je te vois dire oui Kahina
comme Héloïse lui dit dans le
documentaire on se pose la question
est-ce qu'on va faire des enfants parce
que leur futur il est déjà il est déjà
écrit en fait si on continue enfin si
les degrés continuent à augmenter on
sait déjà que le monde est à sa perte
vous êtes d'autres dans le cas de Kahina
vous sentir un peu enfin voilà c'est des
sujets qui sont quand même assez
angoissants Alicia
je me vois pas élever des enfants dans
un monde qui court un peu à sa perte
quoi et
faut avoir de l'espoir mais en même
temps faut aussi être réaliste c'est que
il y a des il y a vraiment des problèmes
et à nous de voir si on a envie de les
de changer ou si on a envie de rester
comme ça Guillaume pensez-vous qu'il y a
davantage de personnes pensant qu'il est
trop tard ou le contraire
les scientifiques qu'est-ce qui nous
disent c'est pas trop tard
j'ai au physiquement il y a rien qui
nous empêche de rester sous les limites
fatidiques de 1.5 et de degrés donc
j'aimerais être très formel là-dessus
c'est tout à fait possible notre
génération et vous en faites partie on
est la dernière qui a cette opportunité
de pouvoir faire quelque chose vos
enfants si vous en avez on passe cette
chance donc on peut faire quelque chose
donc dire on peut rien faire c'est comme
dire ça n'existe pas ou je m'en fiche
c'est pareil non non on peut tout à fait
faire quelque chose maintenant est-ce
qu'on va voir le courage de faire les
choix nécessaires pour que ça arrive je
sais pas mais c'est bien ça la
responsabilité qui nous incombe le
problème vous avez compris il est
compliqué les solutions elles sont
encore plus compliquées personne n'a la
solution pour sortir de notre problème
climatique dans des conditions
acceptables pour les sociétés pas faire
des choix il y aura des gagnants des
perdants donc personne n'a la solution
donc je crois fondamentalement en fait
il faut qu'on se mette ensemble
exactement comme la CCC la montrer
autour de la table pour réfléchir
ensemble
de faire progresser les solutions
pour faire changer les choses ou plus du
tout un constat d'échec
sévère de l'action politique aujourd'hui
face à ces enjeux donc la convention
citoyenne était pour moi à quelque chose
de
dans lequel j'ai plein beaucoup d'espoir
et que je trouve qui était une une
direction intéressante pour renouveler
ce processus décisionnel qui est qui est
aujourd'hui
méfiant ou pas suffisant en tout cas
pour endiguer le changement climatique
donc mais je pense aussi que la
politique c'est la vie de la cité le
renouvellement peut se faire par les
citoyens les citoyens doit se faire par
les citoyens qui doivent à se faire plus
entendre et plus la chose plus engagée
pour renouveler ou forcer les élites à
apprendre les décisions qui sont
nécessaires c'est un sujet éminemment
politique donc pour moi il y a deux
manières de voir les choses où on croit
à la démocratie
et on pense que c'est une des valeurs
les plus fortes à protéger et dans ces
cas-là il faut que ce soit la politique
qui le fasse mais il va falloir changer
nos élites faire les élites aujourd'hui
font un aveu de faillite sur ces sujets
ne sont pas compétentes pour résoudre ce
problème là les émissions n'en font que
monter et j'y crois si on fait pas ça
quand le climat va s'occuper de nous les
valeurs démocratiques vont être celles
qui en première ligne vont tomber
donc oui j'y crois Nathan tu as une
question lors du documentaire on voit le
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe
affirmait que toutes les mesures
proposées par la Convention citoyenne
pour le climat ne pourront être prises
en compte de plus seulement 10% de ses
propositions sont adoptées par la loi
climat à partir de ce bilan avez-vous
déjà perdu espoir dans l'action
politique concernant la lutte contre le
changement climatique bien sûr qu'il y
avait une déception c'est quand même
assez cocasse en fait ce que ça a montré
c'est qu'ils y croyaient pas du tout
ceux qui ont décidé ça puisque au début
ils disent on va reprendre sans fil tous
vos propositions il n'y croyait pas du
tout ils ont été complètement submergés
par l'ambition du niveau de proposition
des citoyens et moi c'est le message que
je veux garder et le message que nous
donne la convention citoyenne c'est que
nous vous si on prend le temps de se
former si on prend le temps de s'engager
on a une force transformationnelle qui
fait peur qui fait peur aux décideurs
ils ont eu peur
donc utilisons cette expérience pour
construire le monde dont on veut on a la
chance d'être dans une démocratie on
peut le faire quand la loi climat a été
lancée on a été sollicité et on a eu des
fresqueurs qui ont monté un programme de
formation des élus notamment député et
sénateurs
qui sont passés par la fresque pour dire
justement cette nécessité de dire si
c'est passé c'est pas passé c'est qu'ils
ont pas compris et que on va devoir nous
s'y coller en nous c'est que trois
heures ça va pas être assez pour donner
le niveau de formation suffisant mais
question elle est pour Baptiste Roger
Michel alors la sociologue chérie
hardstein démontre que la démocratie
participative que ce titarga a trois
grands paliers celui de la manipulation
qui vise à donner l'illusion que les
citoyens peuvent détenir une partie du
pouvoir celui de la coopération
symbolique où on consulte les citoyens
dans un souci d'information et enfin le
partenariat ou les citoyens participent
réellement auprès de décision politique
au regard de votre documentaire je pense
que la CCC a été de manipulation et vous
et vous je pense qu'il y avait un coup
de bluff de du président en disant qu'il
avait donné un bon rôle et le l'image
d'un président progressif progressiste
est ouvert
donc oui une part de manipulation
clairement après je pense qu'il y a eu
effectivement il y a eu un vrai surprise
des citoyens qui ont été citoyens qui
ont été sélectionnés en premier et
finalement après des élus même du
président lui-même sur la qualité et la
technicité des mesures et du travail qui
a été accompli la contradiction que vous
soulève le film c'est qu'en fait les
citoyens citoyens qui ont participé à la
convention à la fin quand ils ont décidé
ils ont proposé ils ont présenté leur
mesure ils avaient le choix entre dire
voilà ces mesures là on va les confier
au Parlement mais au gouvernement et au
Parlement où on va demander ce que hier
un référendum c'est à dire qu'on va se
remettre ces choix là entre les mains
des Français et des Françaises
et bah sauf sur un sujet toutes les
autres mesures n'ont pas été confiées
dans l'entraînement des Français on a
été confié au gouvernement et au
Parlement
Frédéric moi aussi ça m'a beaucoup
perturbé cette réflexion qu'on se dit
après tout ça comment c'est possible
mais je pense que ça a montré aussi
l'humilité de ces personnes qui sont dit
j'ai eu la chance d'être formés et si
les gens n'ont pas cette chance là ils
vont pas pouvoir apprendre les choses
comme il faut et jusque là je suis
d'accord avec eux sauf que après
l'hypothèse c'était les élus sont
correctement formés et là je peux vous
dire que c'est pas du tout du tout le
cas il manque d'un niveau cruel de
formation sur ces sujets et c'est là qui
était l'énorme déception après de des
gens de la Convention
est-ce que la participation citoyenne
va-t-elle vraiment augmenter ou tout
ceci n'est qu'une façade
je comprends cette colère question elle
est pertinente et elle se pose
j'y mets juste un peu de nuance c'est à
dire que quand on a des débats en France
on adore parler politique on adore avoir
des débats on est dans une démocratie en
français si on a un doute on peut aller
pas très loin allons mettre un pied en
Russie pour comprendre un peu ce qui se
passe allons mettre en pied dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays pour se
rappeler la chance qu'on a d'être dans
une démocratie encore faut-il pouvoir
user de ce moyen le plus possible par
exemple moi j'ai appris avec des
Américains qu'on peut écrire à son élu
je sais pas si vous savez ça on peut
écrire à son élu on peut l'interpeller
on peut lui demander des choses on peut
lui demander ce qui compte voter sur une
loi Google lui demander des comptes
quand il a voté sur une loi nous les
français on fait pas ça on n'utilise pas
assez notre pouvoir démocratique donc
moi je me dis pas que c'est la faute des
élus je dis que c'est notre faute c'est
à nous d'aller secouer ce système
démocratique pour lui donner toute la
force qu'il a encore
et moi je dirais que moi je crois
beaucoup
une part plus importante de démocratie
directe une démocratie citoyenne je
pense que ça s'étend on l'a senti que la
convention cette climat c'est qu'en fait
ça crée une vraie révolution de des
pensées et des
Modus open un petit pour la pour les
élus en particulier qui sont été
beaucoup en résistance ils sont parce
que cette convention est un décidée par
le Président de la République et en fait
derrière les élus à l'Assemblée était
majoritairement même s'il le disait pas
officiellement contre en disant nous on
a été élu on a une on a une on a une
légitimité donc ça ça soulève beaucoup
de questions et les vraies questions
parce que c'est vrai que la question
légitimité est une vraie question mais
je crois que
la construction n'est pas la seule piste
mais ça fait ça fait partie des choses
qui à mon avis peuvent
nourrir et aussi permettre à la à la
démocratie de se renouveler
et en se renouvelle en appliquant
beaucoup plus les citoyens citoyenne
donc nous
on va s'arrêter là merci beaucoup merci
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à Z la
Zone d'Éducation en documentaire merci à
vous les élèves bravo vous pouvez vous
applaudir bravo bravo pour vos questions
pour vos réflexions je sais que vous
avez énormément travaillé on peut
féliciter vos professeurs
d'histoire-géographie et votre CPE qui
vous ont si bien préparé pour cette
émission et puis Z revient très très
vite avec une nouvelle classe et un
nouveau documentaire parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ces images allez salut les élèves au
revoir merci
voilà
[Musique]